we are now turning to our series
changing the game where we highlight
extraordinary women who are making a
difference for Asian American and
Pacific Islander heritage month we are
introducing you to two aapi leaders
first generation Vietnamese American
sisters Kim and Vanessa Pham launched
their Asian food brand amsam in 2020.
their products are now sold Nationwide
in stores like Whole Foods and Target
here's a little bit of their story from
tick tock
hi we're Vanessa and Kim Fam Vietnamese
American sisters and Daughters of
refugees growing up we never felt
represented by the ethnic Island
mainstream grocery stores and so we left
our careers in business to start amsan a
proud and loud Asian food brand we make
it super easy for people to bring
restaurant quality Asian flavors into
their home without compromising on
Flavor we partner with iconic Asian
Chefs to craft cooking sauces and Saucy
noodles that pack bold and undiluted
flavor the name of the company actually
originates in the Vietnamese phrase for
Rowdy or rambunctious so join us for
this journey as we bring proud loud
Asian flavors into American homes
here for it Vanessa and Kim Pham join us
now good morning
I love this story I love your products
and in my house uh Saucy noodles we love
them um you started from some because
growing up you didn't feel like you were
represented by the ethnic what is called
the ethnic aisle in grocery stores tell
me a hilarious artifacts yeah very
hilarious artifact where they actually
have a separate section for foods that
are primarily made by American Manual
and what's in what's out of the ethnic
aisle is awesome right pretentious the
lines are very what we're weirdly drawn
yeah I mean Amazon was definitely
informed by our identities as first gen
Vietnamese Americans and daughters or
refugees and I think we just saw this
ethnic aisle as like The Last Vestige of
an Antiquated view of America where it's
this hodgepodge of ingredients and
products across various communities of
color and we're like What would it look
like to start an Asian American brand
that proudly and proudly and loudly
reclaimed and celebrated our flavors and
stories for ourselves and so amsan was
really born from that what does amsam
mean so amsam doesn't mean anything but
it originates from the Vietnamese phrase
umsum which roughly translates to like
row your rambunctious it's actually kind
of a negative term that's what our
parents would use when they were
scolding us oh that's perfect don't be
so um some and we're like What if we
took that energy and like made it ours
well because I love that because the
proud and loud Asian flavors I love that
exactly speaking of the flavors do you
want to do the yeah ready all right here
we go
[Applause]
okay so what are we looking at here
we've got three flavors for you today
from our new Saucy noodle line so we've
got this really Luxe kind of sauce
that's kind of the omsom trademark so I
believe we have garlic black pepper
chili Sesame and garlic today and then
we have these gorgeous knife shaved air
dried noodles you can do a gorgeous
little noodle pull get that sauce yeah
look at that sauce
we grew up on instant noodles but you
know there were fried noodle blocks with
those like dry powdered broths and we
wanted to reinvent them and build make
something that's rustic that's Luxe that
tastes like home for us what how what's
it like for the two of you working
together as sisters because sometimes
the family Dynamic and businesses great
and sometimes it's not so good yeah I
mean in the early days I'm not gonna lie
it was a little rocky especially being
only two years apart you know like
there's that sister rivalry especially
you know
um for us we kind of had to work through
a lot of that but now I don't know we've
I don't know it feels yeah good we've
we've really built some things together
that we're so proud of and I think
because it represents you know the
communities and stories in a way that
feels honorable that's what we like feel
motivated by but yeah to get here we
definitely had to have some real hard
conversations be really vulnerable with
each other what about your families I
mean I know that speaking as a first
generation American and I always tell
the story that my parents had this idea
you're either you're going to be a
doctor a lawyer an engineer and the
fourth option is failure
that's a hobby so what do they say when
you decide
I think they were at first they were
like are you sure they like didn't
believe it until they saw the physical
product and then they believed it and
then they're super supportive now but I
think we're quite lucky that our parents
are quite unorthodox and so really have
been encouraging you know we both quit
our jobs in business and finance to
start omsom and they definitely were
confused at first but now they're our
biggest fans and you did it during the
pandemic
it was a time where nobody knew what to
expect you know what was going to come
next and we had mentors and advisors and
investors tell us to hold and not launch
but ultimately we felt like we were
bringing a taste of our home and that
would that would give people a sense of
comfort a sense of connection which is
what you know amsam is all about well
clearly really good Tony and I don't
like it because we barely barely talking
about
same thing in every Bowl here no they're
different flavors yeah
I don't know but but I will I see what's
going on but and and happiness now from
the family too and the success that you
guys have been able to have they're so
great they're very proud they um when we
first got into Whole Foods they went to
one of the stores and like did a whole
selfie you know Marathon if you will and
I just brought four boxes home to them
and did a taste test with them live and
they were very proud so that's great
what are the famous chefs saying that
you're working I see oh my gosh yeah so
we work with taste makers who are chefs
from every Cuisine because we're
Vietnamese Americans we can't purport to
be experts on all these different
Cuisines and they are loving where it's
Landing the journey is is you know like
definitely a long path where they give
us some really really candid feedback
and that's what makes the products as
special as they are I'm gonna take
another bite but first thank you thank
you so much for being here
and then I will bite come back up next
yeah good kick